almost two months after kim's
convenience abruptly ended with its
season five finale cbu
is given a bit more insight into why the
show
was canceled he wrote a huge facebook
post this morning
detailing his grievances about the show
so simul also denies that his new marvel
role at shanghi
contributed to the show being cancelled
so siemi writes this could not be
further from the truth
i love the show and everything it stood
for i saw firsthand how profoundly it
impacted families and brought people
together
it's truly so rare for a show today to
have such an
impact on people and wanted very badly
to make the schedules work
uh yeah simu also said that uh it would
be
up to the show's producers to resurrect
it not the network he goes on to say
the show can't be quote saved because it
wasn't quote cancelled in a traditional
manner
i.e by network or after poor ratings our
producers who also own the
kim's convenience ip are the ones who
chose not to continue neither the cbc
nor netflix own the rights to kim's
convenience they merely license it
however
the producers of the show are indeed
spinning off a new show
from the shannon character it's been
difficult for me
i love and i'm proud of nicole and i
want the show to succeed
but i remain resentful of all the
circumstances that led to the one
non-asian character getting her own show
and not that they would ever ask but i
will adamantly refuse to reprise
my role in any capacity
this seems like the worst pr movement
cbc's making did you watch kim's
convenience
yeah my parents are obsessed with kim's
convenience it's such a good
show it makes you feel good it makes you
laugh it makes you happy it's nice
seeing
a show um spotlight like i did on an
asia because it's very rare
um yeah it's amazing but this is
it's like it's the drama that you watch
from afar go
down and don't involve yourself because
you wanted to see how it plays out
you know right um
i think that like i miss the show as a
viewer
i think it's an incredible show and it
did suck the way it ended
um and i think where where this comment
is coming from is like
fandoms are incredible but they're all
they also put a really
heavy amount of pressure on you like if
you
if you're part of a culture like for me
i'm a part of the drag race culture and
that fandom
is such a nice niche culture and if if
someone does you wrong
you better believe that those fans are
attacking that person or if you know
they're also the first ones to make fun
of me for my bad snatch game i did on
the show like
they're with you they're against you
they love they hate you and i think
this felt like this statement felt like
a pressure
cooker situation where all the fans were
like where's king kim's convenience we
want it back you're the reason it's not
coming back did this to him being like
was it
me yeah i didn't do it i want to make it
work let's be back this
is this is the situation i think that
some things are better left unsaid and
you have to like leave things to let
them have their
their grace and um he's
yeah there's a bitterness there that's
kind of unsettling because
the show is so celebrated yeah
yeah i've i've i've talked to semu and
paul at
length multiple times about what went
down even behind the scenes
um with this show and the one thing that
that still baffles me is the producers
of this show
going into the last season they had two
stars paul
who became a nerd legend from being on
the mandalorian
and and cimu who was about to become a
marvel superhero
and if i don't understand the reason
that you could not make that work
you had these two individuals who had
become
these two things going into your final
season and you couldn't make that work
and capitalize on that
um that's what i don't understand to me
it sounds extremely personal
in order for that to happen i don't know
what the story is behind that
but i will say as a fan of kim's
convenience i like the show because i
thought the show
was well written and brilliantly acted
and i love the cast
to death as people but that show means
something different to me than it does
to their hardcore audience i was in a
tiny tiny tiny little town
um two and a half hours away from where
i live maybe the town had 4 000 people
in it and i was there for the weekend
and i went into their local convenience
store which was owned by a korean family
and it was the day it was the day before
the long weekend
and i had said hey are you guys open
tomorrow meaning the holiday
and the woman behind the counter looked
at me and said yeah we're open tomorrow
every day we are just like kim's
convenience
and she didn't say it and she didn't say
it in any sort of like
ironic way or stereotypical way she said
it in this there was a there was a such
a
proud moment for her when she knew
that what they do and have always done
is now relatable to people like me
because of that show it's those fans
that deserved the ending that the that
that the show should have done
it's not for me i like the show but
they're hardcore fans
this is a group of people that for the
first time saw
so many families in canada that saw
themselves on television and
to not be able to capitalize on paul and
simu and and sort of service those
hardcore fans that are all across this
country and the world really
um i i have i don't know what they did
it is it is a colossal
mistake whoever those producers are yeah
producers yeah tesco says wow rough
words i can see his anger
yeah we need to hear from these
producers that's the thing that's what
it comes down to why'd they walk away
from the show why did they not let cbc
continue it
and yeah the the the publicity of
they're spinning off the one white
character from the show i don't know
what cbc is thinking
like cbc needs to step in and do
something about this like get the rights
from the producers like it makes no
sense whatsoever like
the times are in right now this is such
an amazing show i don't know what cbc is
thinking i know what these producers are
thinking
but yeah it's not on cmu it's on these
uh producers and cbc to figure this out
because yeah it's just
it just makes no sense whatsoever so i
don't know if there's still hope
but yeah i want to hear from these
producers because it's clearly on them
yeah and i i didn't produce i said
i said promise me right now that you did
not walk in at any point the last two
years after getting a marvel deal
and walk into the cat the to the
producers of kim's convenience and say
i want this this is the dollar figure he
up
and down swore to me that it had
nothing to do with money and it had
nothing to do with schedule
that's unbelievable we gotta call the
producers call misha barton
call barbara walters and we gotta figure
it out
it